and what will prag
do we have the first move okay and it's
the queen's pawn opening from prague uh
prague he plays a variety of openings
thanks to ramesh thanks to some of the
other players he works with he's learnt
a whole bunch of openings during the
lockdown over the last couple of years
and it's a queen's gambit queen's gambit
declined which variation are we going to
see is it going to be the semi tarash
this last movement magnus very solid and
uh will he capture with a pawn now in
the center of the board this is so
trendy so fashionable right now
every top grandmaster playing this line
that means magnus wants to lock this
game down to a draw this is this is
the way to try and draw isn't it now
with black in against well it's one of
the topical lines as you say
everyone's been playing it definitely um
so against one e4 they have the berlin
defense and this is basically the
equivalent
so this is where uh we haven't gone for
the most forcing line where actually
queens often get traded uh pride trying
to keep more tension in the position
which is good i like what prague's doing
but yeah it's uh still been worked out
very deeply this opening it's gonna come
down to who understands the position a
bit more um it's actually also a
transposition to the sicilian defense
with colours reversed and my favorite
variation the c3 sicilian yeah it's
basically a direct transposition just
white having an extra move compared to
that
you know that is i think a sign of
respect
and actually retreating the queen is
not necessarily the most popular move
no more kind of wild chaotic openings
provoking his opponent and okay he plays
maybe the most safe choice in this
position just developing black's bishop
giving prague the time to castle and uh
ivanka uh the move you called there
on the board now often white now
challenges this black queen with white
tone queen it's actually a very sneaky
porn move
and uh it looks like you know white
isn't actually defending the pawn that's
under attack but if black were to get
greedy and snap the pawn well there
would be problems ahead and
bring both of them towards the center
now and there we go he starts by
mobilizing his remaining pieces
and uh nice to have you watching and
honeybees is also watching from orlando
florida and remember we love seeing your
selfies what's happening in the game
david quickly please we do have a few
moves
past everyone's bedtime here
and we do have those few moves uh white
pushed upon gaining some space on that
left flank and actually magnus took a
decision i don't really approve of
magnus just pushing one of his his own
black pawns and that has allowed prague
time to centralize one of the white
rooks and black had the extra tempo so
i've had this position but with black to
play basically knight to c3 that's right
and uh i don't know what i don't know
what lawrence has paid jordan to play
that move or one night c3 but it's a
great advert for lawrence's course and
he's got a great position as well jordan
he knows his stuff incredibly well so
it's well worth checking out um but yeah
it's quite funny to see he brings the
course out and uh meanwhile white has
moved the rook and aligned it to look at
the black queen and uh magnus moves his
queen
he spent four minutes out of 12 that he
had and okay he actually plays the move
that i was recommending um the reason i
recommend this is because it's very
typical from the position with colors
reversed that lawrence was mentioning
there and uh black does the same i don't
think he won the tournament um i think
it might be in that year very close to
there but i played i played him in the
blitz tournament afterwards and he took
my king in a blitz tournament we got
down to a time scramble
that made him so great as well as his
hard work as well and there was the the
mozart of chess comments that's when the
the kind of nicknames the kind of labels
started coming but he was already a
grandmaster then
at a young age and players they get good
and then they stop but not for magnuson
clearly not for prague knights are the
best blockaders if you plant your knight
in front of your opponent's isolated
pawns they can never ever be moved so
keep those selfies coming absolutely
keep those moves coming indeed prague is
trying to up the pressure he's putting a
lot of um well he's actually creating a
threat right now if you look at black's
light square bishop it's under fire from
white's bishop that's just moved and
white's knight in the center of the
board
oh okay he does move it he does retreat
it
uh oh somehow it feels like that's a
step in the wrong direction to me i
thought maybe he would protect it with
the black queen yeah look at the bar
yeah at the edge of the board it doesn't
look like the most attractive oh we see
a trade yeah and this is the move i was
expecting because now white knight can
occupy that dream f5 square but we might
be able to highlight that pawn and it's
kind of like a hook and you see it is on
f5 and that is now hitting that hook as
well which you might be able to at some
point start a sacrifice on so aggressive
play from prague
very aggressive it's all about this
knight right now putting pressure on
this bishop if this bishop ever moves
then suddenly the white bishop can
capture the black knight safely and
completely wreck the black pawn
structure
a lot of pressure right now it's all
about this night putting pressure on the
bishop as simon says maybe sacrificing
itself on the square to open up the
black king maybe even sacrificing itself
on this square to be fair to him does
have chances it's against these weak
white pawns later in the game and maybe
he will try and stack up the two black
rooks to create some counter threats
along this line and we do have another
move in the big one and simon you must
be loving this last night it's the first
place i've thought of yeah i mean i want
to get all my pieces towards black's
king i love the the swinger the swinging
brook yeah this rook move looks really
nice really pretty planting the rook on
an outpost and trying to as you
mentioned simon swing it across to the
black king uh we call this a rook lift
you lift it up the board and then you
lift it across towards your
targets here the target is the black
king it's certainly not a draw and he
any he's going for it i mean this is
this is really brave stuff and uh there
we go he's played at two black rooks
creating big big threats now they look
good and uh remember this is the big one
today the match up on the podium but if
you are following us on twitch chess24
on twitch if you want to use the command
center wow bunch of moves yeah bunch of
moves and a rook trade i think that's
good for prague's short term because
he's released some of the pressure the
two black ropes were just too strong but
long term if white's attack doesn't work
then white is just saddled with
weaknesses uh the simon mentioned
earlier if you can move that okay this
is why magnus had to play uh something
that ivanka just mentioned and go for
the offensive because that white knight
is two squares from an ideal situation
white's pieces are are quite scary as
well oh wait one second isn't there okay
knight takes rook yeah i was expecting
the white rook
there's a big threat rook takes knight
oh look at the bar oh no is it a blunder
by prague look at him it's a big blunder
by prague unfortunately and he's just
missed that black can actually sacrifice
a queen on the next turn he thought that
the white knight could come and check
the black king but it doesn't work and
we'll have to show that in a moment but
prague first of all is heartbreak for
him big big blunder there he actually
had a very good move the white rook
could have just moved out of the attack
moved out of the threat and the game
goes on uh prague would have had decent
chances but magnus there he knows he's
winning now the white knight forced to
retreat to attack black's queen but
that's not what prague wanted head in
his hands he's just lost a rook for only
one piece
win five world championship matches
without uh having nerves of steel
and simon's move there offering a queen
trade and also threatening checkmate the
queens have to come off the board
and uh here we go it's actually still a
rook for a bishop advantage for black
but more importantly white's pieces were
attacked and there we go just a trade of
knights there and when the black knight
moves out of the way it's just uh an
endgame
where black has extra material and a
matter of technique as we call it
the black knight retreating out of the
threat attacking white's bishop and now
the black rook is going to go and grab
some pawns the white bishop not able to
fight against blackstroke serious
blunder when you do it i think i you
know i don't know why that is always but
and it's so strange you know when you're
like well brain if you if you could work
one second later why could you not
exactly why
but this this is yeah this is pretty
the rook is so strong here um you know
it's it's a rook in an ending incredibly
good piece and it can start picking off
the white pawns so it it's yeah there's
not much that can be done here already
in his three match wins uh in previous
days he was losing games in all of those
three days
but he managed to win them in the end uh
the problem is this is not that type of
position where you can confuse your
opponent
really yeah he's dependent on a mouse
slip or blunder really from magnus
carlsen and less than a minute on the
clock now for pragnanda if he loses this
game then magnus will only need a draw
in game three with the white pieces to
take the win in the match
it's getting quite dramatic now for
prague
and uh i think we're going to see a
result any moment this last move is
really nice look at the white bishop it
lacks escape squares black has a huge
threat of just retreating the black rook
up to the top of the board and white's
bishop is caught
in behind enemy lines if you're if your
phone goes off do you still lose
in the esports arena
because obviously if you're playing
chess over the board and your phone goes
off
do you immediately lose okay the game's
over yeah
it's uh
over magnus carlsen winning game two as
well he is up by two points in the big
match